joining us now Fox News contributor
former Speaker of the House and the
creator of defending America course it's
on his website Newt Gingrich's with us
sir how are you I'm doing well and and I
have to say I don't think when this book
came out and the tour began I didn't
really expect the level of shrinkage you
know he's going from six foot eight by
the tour I think will be about five foot
two I mean liberals are attacking him
the members of the of the Obama
administration are attacking him
conservatives are attacking him he's
managed to have a range of people
describe him as dishonest that is really
pretty remarkable and one time I got
what my favorite was I think he six
eight the former FBI target hiding
trying to hide with the blue curtain to
avoid the president like really you've
gotta be kidding me but you know he's a
very big guy physically but I do think
psychically he has been shrinking with
every interview and and I got intrigued
this morning so I went back I reread rod
Rosen's teens report which he gave to
President Trump just before the
president fired call me and then I read
the recently released inspector
general's report on mccabe and what's
really sobering and here I think what
Alan Dershowitz was saying is so
important you had the number one and
number two people in the Federal Bureau
of Investigation both engaged in
behavior that clearly violated the law I
mean I think the the whole depth the
idea that the top two people and what is
our preeminent law enforcement agency in
the entire country the therapy of
Investigation literally now you've had
an internal report by the inspector
general saying McCabe clearly lied you
had this analysis by by Rob Rosenstein
which if you've never read
but he's really staggering in the degree
to which it repudiates Comey and that's
the what President Trump got just before
he decided to fire these two taken
together it's very sobering to think you
had that depth of corruption at the very
top of the FBI well then look at all the
people that have had either been demoted
or McCabe fired or in people that will
be fired I'm sure as a result of this
and then ultimately I do believe
criminal action will be taking place I
want to go back to this important
question you know we have a FISA Court I
can't imagine James Comey saying well it
could be true
at this late date meaning the Clinton
bought and paid for Russian dossier and
that that was and he knew she paid for
it and that was the basis the Grassley
grant memo the bulk of the application
that they use to get the warrant to spy
on a trump campaign associate that to me
is criminal you don't lie before a judge
nor do you write exonerations before you
even interview the person he did that to
well coming from you clearly if you were
to go through all of the falsehoods
where they're talking to Congress or in
other circumstances all the things that
commis done clearly there are a
substantial number of indictable grounds
the cases made today by a very senior
attorney in Washington writing in a
legal journal that if you read the
Inspector General of McCabe McKay
basically did exactly what general Flynn
did now look how general Flynn has been
treated and then look where McCabe is
right this man so clearly if you were to
apply the law and not just apply the
social norms among good friends both
McCabe and Co me I think would be a very
serious so legal risk at this stage the
new Comey standard if we're going to use
the Comey standard number one I guess
everybody's part of a crime family if
you disagree with James Comey which is
outrageous in and of itself but the
standard is it might be possible then
let's therefore present it to a judge so
the judge won't know who paid for it the
judge won't know it's it's unverified
and the judge will then issue a warrant
to spy on an American citizen because it
may be possible it's possible well okay
it's the number one thing to recognize
that if everything was learned from
James Comey is that this is the world
according to Comey in which Comey is
always right so at every stage if
somebody else disagreed he's
disappointed in them he doesn't and this
is a point that made my Rosenstein and
his memo to the president that Comey
seems incapable of learning from his
mistakes or incapable of even thinking
that their mistakes and so I mean the
level of danger we had in having an FBI
director who had this level of
megalomania and who decided that he
would supplant the Attorney General I
know they like or dislike Loretta Lynch
she was the Attorney General now no FBI
director has the authority to decide
that he will now replace her and yet
that's what he did and when explaining
why he had to announce what he did about
Hillary Clinton that he was protecting
the institution wasn't his job to
protect the institution it's an act of
stunning arrogance to believe that he
was the only perfect person in an
otherwise flawed world yeah all right
mr. speaker always good to hear your
insight